pues la situación es que ahora lo último
es un toque de queda que se ha decretado
que se endurece y que a partir de se
entra en vigor
de hecho acaba de entrar en vigor porque
son las cinco y dos minutos y se
mantendrá este toque de queda de esta
forma porque en la ciudad según algunas
informaciones habría saboteadores rusos
y los ucranianos tendrían la intención
de perseguirlos buscarlos para que no
dañen sus estructuras esta mañana de
hecho hemos estado en la calle y hemos
visto una situación muy tensa
algunos hemos visto la detención de una
persona en la calle que tras un forcejeo
se ha tirado al suelo y luego ha sido
detenido por las fuerzas ucranianas
y de irene el kremlin dijo que había
detenido ayer la incursión a la espera
de una respuesta de excelencia para
negociar y que ante la negativa decidió
retomar la invasión y lo anunciaron hace
poco es cierto que rusia detuvo los
ataques momentáneamente
lo que le puedo decir que es que
nosotros nos despertamos esta mañana a
las 5 de la mañana con el nuevo
estallido un estallido que pero procedía
de una zona cercana al parlamento de la
casa de gobierno que es una zona muy
central y luego durante el día también
estando en la calle hemos oído diversos
disparos diversos estallidos y esta es
una situación que ya se está volviendo a
la normalidad por tanto diría que esos
estos enfrentamientos están continuando